so edgar
this movie has been a seed in the back
of your mind for a long long time what
was it that kept you going back to it
and keeping it alive i think because i
spend too much time in soho so it's kind
of inescapable it's been haunting me for
so long because uh you know like soho in
london is the center of the film and tv
industry and i actually
in the last five years i've actually
lived very close by so
you know i literally walked past what
would become the locations of the movie
every day so i couldn't stop thinking
about it a certain point is like i have
to make this movie and get it out of my
system and then it feels like christy
you were the missing piece you came into
the picture and now we have the movie
well i spent a lot of time in soho as
well i worked in the bar that's in the
film i lived above a strip club and when
edgar and i first met he told me the
story that he had um and it sort of just
knocked my socks off so yeah when he
asked me to write it i was very happy
instant yes oh my god yeah i don't even
think you finished your sentence yes
just over it
um i love i love that there are so many
women in this movie i love all of the
female female characters in this movie
and it really feels like they're kind of
reclaiming the idea of what a woman was
in the 60s that we used to see was that
a conscious effort for both of you
well i think there was a lot of one of
the inspirations for the movie was
watching a lot of 60s dramas where there
are a lot of those narratives about
girl comes to london and has the
audacity to want to make it big and
she'll be roundly punished for it and i
saw a lot of those movies and i thought
this is interesting that it seemed like
there was very these movies were very
sort of punitive and um so then it's oh
i had the idea of like what if you saw
like a modern girl coming to london who
wants to escape back into the
seemingly more glamorous
like london of the 60s and i guess gets
a rude awakening and this movie really
doesn't exist without anya and thomason
what was it about them that made the
sort of perfect counterpart for one
another on screen
well um
the irony is is when
i i talked to anya about it maybe three
years before we'd written the first
draft
and initially i was thinking of her
playing the eloise character but then
when we started writing we started
expanding the sandy character
and by this point i'd seen anya in some
other movies and also i got an idea of
what else she could do so i was thinking
maybe annie should play the 60s part and
she totally agreed and was like i'd love
to play that part so
it was great and then and then we went
looking for eloise which we found in the
amazing form of thomas and mckenzie
you also have this amazing veteran cast
as well you've got
uh you know you've got dame diana rigg
you have margaret nolan you have you
know these just amazing actors was it
easy to get them on board
i mean
yeah in the sense that they all wanted
to do it absolutely like so that was
that in a way like having written a film
that's partly takes place in the 60s
and then having some of these icons be
in the movie and get their perspective
on the script was like you know really
validating for both of us
um
and you know just working with like with
the touching him and tearing stamp just
um
you know it was it was incredible
and what about for you christy is that
sort of a moment when you have these
icons come on board as a film fan is
that just like blowing your mind yeah i
mean i used to watch the avengers like
the diana rig maple avengers when i was
very young she was like the first female
superhero i'd ever watched on screen and
yeah getting to meet her and getting to
hear her you know act words that you had
written is sort of like totally i mean
it's a memorial treasure always it's
incredible that it it is her final role
and it's just she's
not she's so phenomenal in it it was so
great to see her on screen um i like
that one of the themes here is that
nostalgia and looking back at the past
is kind of dangerous it's not you know
what what we
when we're looking at it with
rose-colored glasses are you both people
who
do do you get caught up in nostalgia
when you look back at the past do you
tend to look at it with those
rose-colored glasses i think this film
is my attempt to cure that
so i would say yes so like a hopeless
nostalgic but i think in a way what the
movie is about is like the sort of the
danger of doing that people always talk
about the good old days like there was
some perfect decade where everything was
great and nothing was bad and of course
it's a fallacy it doesn't exist
and same for you yeah the same for me i
just think obviously i would love to be
able to time travel and visit the 60s
but i wouldn't hang around for too long
um and yeah i think nostalgia is so easy
for everyone to be like it would have
been great it would have been amazing
that would have been my decade but live
in the here and now and eloise you know
dreams of being a fashion designer when
you were her age what was the dream for
you was it this
yeah
yeah i mean i
i i sort of was in you know wanted to
kind of be
a director from like when i was i knew i
wanted to do something in film and when
i was about 14 i saw a documentary about
sam raimi making the evil dead at age 18
and i was like
i want to do that
like that's what i want to do and it was
sort of a real like lightning bolt
moment of like going into school the
next day saying okay this is this is
what i'm gonna do with no idea of how to
do it or like no connections with the in
in the industry whatsoever so
then
it was but that was the start of the
journey i guess
i always feel when i'm watching your
movies that you open up this wormhole
where of discovery where people want to
go in and look at you know what movies
what music you're listening to what sort
of is in this world i know sparks
brothers so many people say they've just
discovered sparks
uh with this movie what would you
suggest people watch and listen to after
watching last night in soho
well i mean
there's definitely i don't ever people
to feel that there's required reading
before i think in in a way
like eloise you know you can just go on
the journey with her but um you know i'm
excited for the soundtrack to come out
that's really been asking me about that
and you know that will be out closer to
the release um but you know like i mean
in in when we were writing the movie
like i i had actually sort of just been
diving into kind of like
british cinema the stuff that i hadn't
seen like not so much the psychological
thrillers and horror films like you know
i was so well versed in that so actually
watching a lot of like 60s dramas
the lesser known ones has been that's
just an ongoing gift for me
and i know when we spoke to you for baby
driver you had written the script uh you
know in your cast said like you gave
them a playlist to listen to while they
were reading through the script was that
the same with this one
i think it's the first thing that i said
christy was like here are the songs here
are the songs and the exact songs that
were like now in the finished film and
it was incredible because like usually
music is much later in my other kind of
like working relationships and having
that like i would cycle into our office
listening to the tracks being like okay
today i'm gonna write something that
works with this it's really good fun
and then there's a lot of in this movie
a lot of
mirrors and camera tricks that go into
it can you talk a little bit about some
of the practical stuff that you did
especially with the mirror and down the
stairs sort of scene or the dancing
scene yeah i mean the thing that i hope
uh
you know people kind of like don't
really know exactly how things are done
and you don't really want to reveal
exactly
uh how the tricks work but the thing i'd
say is that more of it is happening for
real in front of you than you would
think
like so there maybe isn't a reliance on
green screen or motion control
in too many sort of scenes there's a lot
of it where it's like just kind of
magic circle stuff like where you know
mirrors are sliding back or we have
double sets or you have
identical twin actors kind of on either
side of the mirror so that stuff was
really
fun to design and then just takes an
enormous amount of rehearsal from all
departments
like you know you have a choreographer
and you and thomason need to be doing
exactly the same thing
the camera operator needs to be in
exactly the right place so they're
tricky shots to pull off but like when
they do work it's such a sort of great
feeling because
you know sometimes when you're making a
movie with effects and people kind of
who are making the movie don't really
know what it's going to look like but
when you pull off a shot in camera
everybody is crowded around the monitor
because it's like hey it works
you know so it's always a thrilling
feeling doing stuff like that and you
said that your mom hasn't seen it yet is
she is she a tough critic
uh i mean i'm really excited for my mum
and dad to see it because i guess my
obsession with the 60s started with them
because
you know they were they were both around
they were like art college in the 60s
and
you know my obsession with the decades
sort of starts with their record
collection
so i'm excited for them to see the movie
and it's been you know it's been so long
since scott pilgrim you've spent so much
time in toronto do you still feel like
an honorary torontonian
i did when i got in this is my first
transatlantic flight in like 20 months
and so when i woke up the next morning
after the flight i went wandering to
find my old apartment
i had a dark horse express though i was
like oh yeah i remember toronto
i know i love it here i you know i would
love the opportunity to come back and
shoot here again if it came out yeah and
i mean hopefully next film back in the
festival so you can experience what it's
like you know in a full festival
experience with the crowds in it well
you know like like i think i said this
last night when we were introducing it
is like we didn't take any of this for
granted i think in this kind of day and
age like people who love cinema and like
going to see something on the big screen
like all of these moments of pressure so
it meant a lot to us to just be there
last night
you